Bonjour !
Comment ça va en 2019 ?
Bien ?
C'est toujours Vladimir Cagnolari et j’émets depuis Abidjian en 2069.
Pour vous c'est dans 50 ans.
Aujourd'hui c'est un jour férié sur tout le continent,
parce qu'on fête les 20 ans des états unis d'afrique,
ce vieux rêve de Kwame Nkrumah qui est
enfin devenu réalité en 2049.
L'Afrique a enfin sa monnaie unique, son marché unique
et les linguistes ont même planché pour mettre au point une langue africaine commune que tous les enfants,
en plus de leur langue maternelle,
apprennent dès le plus jeune âge.
Bref, en 2069 l'Afrique est unie, stable et
elle ne connaît plus le terrorisme
depuis que des programmes de
désenvoûtement ont été mis au point pour
refroidir le coeur des extrémistes fous
de dieu.
Oui ! Car enfin si dieu est sage...
il n'a certainement pas besoin de fous.
Pour moi l'Afrofuturisme , c'est une arme de déconstruction massive.
Un champ des possibles, en fait, qui est infini...
Lors de mes dernières transmissions,  je vous ai parlé de l’enquête que j'avais mené en 2019 sur l'Afrofuturisme.
Vous l'avez compris, le mot et un couvercle qui s'ouvre sur un océan de questions
de réflexions et de visions les plus diverses.
Voilà pourquoi il n'en existe pas une seule et unique définition.
Mais tout de même, on retrouve toujours cette idée de sortir des modèles imposés
pour s'inventer un nouveau futur hors des cadres préétablis.
Et puisque la technologie court plus vite que son ombre,
et bien il s'agit de tirer partie d'elle pour servir ce projet libérateur.
Si vous m'avez suivi jusqu'ici,
les afrofuturismes (oui, mieux vaut en parler au pluriel) ont d'abord et avant tout été l'oeuvre d'artistes.
quels que soient leurs domaines.
Oui car ce sont bien les artistes qui
ont ces visions,
qui laissent galoper leur imagination et qui nous raconte des choses sur ce que nous sommes
et sur ce que nous pourrions être.
Après les pionniers des années 70, dont je vous parlais tantôt,
il y eut toujours des artistes pour s'inscrire dans les chemins Afrofuturistes.
Mais le phénomène a repris de la vigueur dans les années 2000.
Et en 2019, quand j'étais encore
votre contemporain,
on peut même dire qu'il était en vogue dans les pays occidentaux.
Cette année là, lors du festival sons
d'hiver à paris,
j'avais croisé les "Shabazz Palaces", un duo de musiciens emblématiques de cette vague.
Tous deux venaient de
Seattle aux états unis.
L'un était originaire du Zimbabwe et s'appelait Tendai Baba Maraire
et l'autre était américain.
Afro-américains !
C'est avec Ishmael Butler que j'ai le plus discuté avant leur concert.
c'est lui qui a choisi le nom du groupe Shabazz Palaces...
Shabazz en référence à Malek El-Shabazz,
le nom que choisit Malcom x lors de sa conversion à l'islam.
Dans les deux derniers albums du groupe,
Ishmael est devenu "Quazarz",
un alien qui découvre la terre en 2017.
Son nom est directement inspiré des quasars, un terme emprunté à l'astronomie.
J'ai découvert que les quasars sont les choses les plus lointaines
que l'on puisse voir dans l'espace
grâce aux puissantes technologiques qu'il a mise au point.
J'aime les caractéristiques des Quasars
qui explosent, créent des galaxies des univers, des planètes.
Et ça m'intéressait !
Car on peut transposer cette symbolique.
En faisant de la musique ,
on crée des mondes,
on crée des explosions qui donnent naissance à de nouvelles choses
J'aime ce concept !
C'est pourquoi, j'ai choisi ce nom.
"Quazarz", le personnage, vient d'un autre endroit,
et il arrive ici, dans notre temps.
Il fait des observations produit
raconte et aussi produit des vibrations à travers la musique.
Car, il vit tout entier dans la musique...
Quazarz débarque donc sur terre et atterrit
précisément aux états unis,
où Donald Trump vient de devenir président.
Ce pays, il l'appelle "Amurderica",
un jeu de mots sur "Murder" - le meurtre -
et "America".
Comprenez donc "l'amérique meurtrière".
Il y a des guerres qui durent depuis
des années dans certains
et elles font autant de morts qu'on en
fait chercher dans nos villes à 1040
valent les violences dans les fusillades
massive dans les lieux publics les
meurtres d'enfants
nous sommes dans un endroit où leur note
fait partie de l'adn du pays c'est
triste mais on entend parler de ce choc
entre novak on aime chacun de nous
connaît une personne qui s'est faite su
voir plusieurs personnes stram gram
voilà pourquoi je dis que c'est la carte
de visite de notre pays qu'est ce que ce
serait à vous votre définition de
l'offre au futurisme c'est un terme
qu'on entend beaucoup mais pour vous
spécifiquement qu'est ce que ça veut
dire
définition c'est quelqu'un qui ne voient
pas le temps avance et douanière de
linéaire le passé en prison et le futur
existe simultanément se chevauchent se
mélangent bas comme des proches à se
superposent et c'est ballot les membres
de futur
l'idée c'est de se souvenir du futur
actionnaire
elle finit donc l'on est présent comme
connecté avec le futur tout autant
qu'avec le passé et donc il s'agit a
changé son mode de pensée un acceptant
cette réalité changé physiquement
mentalement ça maniable
se souvenir du futur voilà un des
maîtres mots d'ismaël butler et c'est
une phrase tout aussi lunaires et
mystérieuse que la musique des shabazz
palaces les palais de shahbaz un groupe
que n'aurait pas renié seule loi dont je
vous ai parlé dans ma dernière
transmission
oui parce que comme sonnera avec ses
synthétiseurs des shabazz palaces et se
sont appropriés les technologies
électroniques prêtes à toutes les
expérimentations pour servir leur
musique mais depuis ce sera la
préfecture is ne s'est pas contenté
d'inspirer les afro américains n'ont
qu'à traverser l'atlantique
il ya d'abord touché les afrodescendants
et puis il a gagné les côtes de
l'afrique là qui a trouvé à qui parler
des plasticiens des poètes des
performeurs certes pas nombreux mais
aussi des musiciens comme ce jeune
sénégalais que vous avez peut être déjà
aperçu sur ces machines pourtant sur sa
tête est très rigide qui un peu comme
les branches d'un arbre sans feuilles
s'élance vers le ciel
salam aleikoum le suivi bakou et je suis
très enrhumé il bat coup c'est waouh
c'est un personnage c'est les deux à la
base il va pousser mon vrai prénom c'est
un peu un prénom qui dormait depuis que
je suis née et que j'ai reçus citer que
j'ai raviver que j'aimerais utiliser
comme un an d'artistes en fait comme
beaucoup de sénégalais beaucoup
d'africains raisons non occidentales un
nom africain
donc mon nom aux jo la et ses bas coût
qui veut dire l'aîné aussi joe là c'est
une population qui est du côté de la
casamance sud du sénégal
c'est aussi l'ethnie de laquelle ses
origines par mon père ça c'est le côté
diola mais le côté personnages dehiba
coup est venu en travers sur le projet
alim cartoon qui est à la base un défilé
performance la collection de sévir habib
khan qui est une artiste sénégalaise
designer
très très très très talentueuse
dakaroise donc on travaille avec elle
l'idée nous est venue tous les deux de
sortir ma bande son de cette fashion
performants cette performance comme une
extension de sa collection en fait
j'étais un défilé au départ auquel il a
convié à participer pouvoir tout à fait
c'était un défilé à la biennale dak'art
moi j'étais à la musique pour imaginer
un peu cette mettre en musique cet
univers futuriste scénario qu'elle avait
en tête qui est une ville africaine qui
en contact avec des extraterrestres et
donc en développant cette idée de de
bande son qui serait l'extension de la
collection je me suis aussi commencent à
imaginer qu'elle rejoint sur scène
comment je pourrais les défendre sur
scène et donc le personnage d'eli bakou
est né comme ça en fait
et ce personnage d'un personnage hybride
en fait il a une histoire dans cette
ville
et c'est cette histoire qui raconte tout
au long de l'album est sur scène aussi
quoi est ce que tu peux te la raconter
un petit peu l'histoire du bac ou bac ou
est un hybride
il est issu d'une aliens et deux êtres
humains en fait ça mais rêver un peu
comme une une pionnière en fait sur
terre elle vient pour voir un peu
comment ça se passe sur terre pour
pouvoir prévoir et une arrivée imminente
des aliens et donc elle tombe amoureuse
de mon père dont elle reste sur terre et
poursuit sa mission en fait les aliens
arrive sur terre recherche ma mère
d'abord et aussi pour accomplir leur
mission sur terre et y bakou est un peu
comme entre ces deux entités et se
retrouve un peu comme un lien forcément
entre ces deux entités avec sa musique
avec ses fréquences avec avec ses super
pouvoirs
il sait quoi séduire pouvoir le plus
évident ce sont ses cheveux en fait il
communique avec ses cheveux ses cheveux
sont un peu comme un récepteur en fait
pour communiquer avec les aliens pour
communiquer avec les esprits car sur
terre
voilà c'est un des ses pouvoirs
le plus visible quoi et donc la
succession des titres de ton album
raconte cette histoire là il ya un clip
et un titre donc ian fogg qui je pense
correspond à une des étapes justement de
l'histoire du bas coûts ça signifie quoi
yann fouilles
voyant que forgo il veut dire à moore en
langue aliens c'est un wolof assez fade
il faut que l'on ait fait ça va ça
pourrait verser près de ressembler à du
wolof ou à du crr qui a la langue de ma
mère et donc voilà c'est ça veut dire à
moore allant gagner voilà il ya beaucoup
de symboles que symbolique
dans ce clip déjà là la symbolique de la
renaissance parce qu'on me voit dans un
cocon et c'est carrément le moment où il
va couronner est en tout cas c'est vrai
qu'on y voit c'est très beau d'ailleurs
l'éclosion du bac ou de son cocon avec
les antennes dressées vers le ciel
on suit aussi beaucoup mes parents tu
vois dans leur errance dans cet endroit
un peu à post apocalyptique un peu dire
que c'est la fin du monde
personne n'a pas eu dans dans les rues
car le mans et pourtant ils sont
lumineux et fort dans l'eure laura par
an ils sont en blanc mais ils sont
masqués quand même il son espèce de
résident dentelle blanche sur la figure
donc on devine appellent leurs visages
donc il ya cette idée d'espoir cette
idée d'un potentiel d'une force qui est
caché qui est masqué qui restreinte en
fait qui a besoin de s'exprimer de se
dévoiler et donc ouais l'amour qu'ils
ont tous les deux va se matérialiser par
ça en fait je lis beaucoup et un peu le
fruit de tout ce potentiel tout cet
amour de cet espoir toujours ce symbole
de la mer de l'eau qui est omniprésent
dans mon travail artistique aussi depuis
quelques années plus que j'ai commencé
en fait je me rends compte de plus en
plus
là un autre clip sur lequel j'aimerais
bien que tu nous raconte aussi comment
il a été fait c'est alors j'ai pas bien
comment on vit ses proches ou ses
chaînes bardon bah oui évidemment tu
peux dire que c'est fun aussi à mon
accent tordez et on s'aperçoit un peu
d'ailleurs comme dorian sugoi on est
dans des univers justement un peu
apocalyptique comme si la terre avait
été désertée par les humains quand après
une catastrophe nucléaire
pourquoi tu as envie de te projeter dans
des univers de ce genre là
la première chose qui me vient à
l'esprit c'est un peu de mou dans lequel
le monde est en fait en ce moment tu
vois mais vu que nous sommes des
pouvait-on n'exagère tu vois on exerce à
et pouvoir avoir un recul de pouvoir
poétiser ce mal être utilisé ce constat
qu'on trouve trés trés semble souvent tu
vois pas ce que dans l'histoire de l'iba
coup il ya 70 ans y ont justement quand
les aliens arrive sur terre et cette
thématique des aliens peut être
transposée à plein de sujets en fait ça
peut être transposé au sujet de
l'immigration c'est la différence tout
simplement en fait c'est le sujet de la
différence en fait c'est pas du tout
rouge justement ces thématiques où la
réalité de ces choses et donc comme je
disais nous sommes des poètes et on
exagère ces choses là
et on essaie de se placer dans ces
décors et d'être des super héros et de
changer certaines choses d'amener des
métaphores de travail sur l'imaginaire
des personnes qui ont regardé et donc
d'emplois séssion quand j'écoutais le
morceau javel avait l'impression
d'entendre des machines qui pétait les
plombs on peut en fait tu vois en étant
à kinshasa nous avons rencontré jeunes
super talentueux daniel toya qui est à
un artiste sculpteur qui se construit
des robots avec du matériel recyclé en
fait qu' un jeune super intéressant dans
la on l'a rencontré le lendemain en
l'état rendent retourner en fait on a eu
cette idée de faire une procession avec
ce héros avec ses robots en fait est
qu'on a vu l'endroit où il exposait ses
robots on était sur le cul pour l'été
avec ok c'est les chargeurs de kinshasa
ça a été créée du temps de mobutu et il
a toute une histoire et les charges et
d'une énergie ça se voit quand on le
connaît on est sur place et donc voilà
c'est un lieu vraiment lunaire cac a
l'air d'une piste de décollage plusieurs
fêtes et la fusée bobo milieu de
kinshasa énorme qui fait des mètres et
des mètres et tout autour il ya 10 à les
décors incroyables qui sont justes je
suis dans l'impression qu'ils sont figés
dans le temps en fait cédé que 7 ont pas
et fizi dans le temps et daniel thomas
est un peu comme un thé lui qui rêvait
les robots qui nous amène dans ce lieu
là en fait tu vois qu'il représente
aussi la folie la folie humaine comme tu
vois aussi la folie humaine de nos
dictatures qui représente toute chose
pour un gars de kinshasa pour un
africain est donc cette procession le
but de cette procession ajustement de
conjurer un peu toute cette folie là en
fait soit c'est de vraiment utiliser cet
endroit à un autre à un autre fin en
fait c'est un peu comme le la statue de
la renaissance à dakar quoi tu vois on
vous conte sur des énormes
déshonneur statut alors que alors que le
peuple est en train de mourir de faim là
ça tu es là quoi donc faut en faire
quelque chose quoi faut faire quelque
chose de
quelque chose de positive quelque chose
de guérisseur quelque chose de fort
quelque chose qui me représente abidjian
2069 la réalité est loin des visions
dystopique catastrophique que véhiculent
les clips du bas coûts mais c'est sans
doute grâce à ce genre d'avertissement
aussi que les choses ont peu changé
depuis lors si aujourd'hui 2069 comme
dans le reste du continent
on a réintroduit les veillées de contes
par des conteurs un pas par de vulgaires
smartphones et au village comme en ville
eh bien on se berce le soir aux
histoires de leuk le lièvre à nancy
l'araignée ou de bum le phacochère et
tant d'autres personnages qu'on voit
d'ailleurs aussi dans les dessins animés
3d conçus dans les studios de ouaga et
qui sont copiés 1 dans le monde entier y
compris par les japonais adieu aussi les
séries brésilienne dona beija et
consorts sont retournés à rio et les
personnages du feuilleton ivoirien ma
famille 70e saison en ce moment sont
partis s'installer sur mars pour y
exporter le savoir faire ivoiriens en
matière d'ambiance et sociétés elles
aussi ont changé
oui certaines ont décidé de rééquilibrer
les choses et d'inaugurer la polyandrie
oui la polyandrie c'est quand une femme
peut avoir plusieurs maris donc
messieurs préparez vous le futur nous
réserve bien des surprises bien mais
revenons à 2019 évidemment quand j'étais
avec iba coup je lui ai demandé cette
définition à lui de l'afro futurisme
je vais paraphraser
marina est aussi une amie à moi qui a
beaucoup réfléchi sur ces thématiques
qui fait partie d'un collectif ça peut
être black's de futures et qui dit que
pour elle la future is est une suite
infinie de hashtags ça veut dire quoi
concrètement ça veut dire que ça veut
dire que il ya plusieurs perspectives
alors afro futuriste c'est un mouvement
c'est une idéologie qui serait défini
qui grandit tous les jours et je vais
paraphraser encore une autre nana berck
c'est habib khan qui m'a dit que c'était
un gros point d'interrogation pour elle
qu'est-ce qui est l'afrique dans le
futur qu'est ce que ce sera les les
cultures noires qu'est ce que sera la
diaspora africaine
ouais pour moi la france future in c'est
une noble des constructions massives tu
vois pas ce que mais c'est même pas moi
qui les disent effet là qu'il a dit en
fait parce qu'il dit que c'est une arme
du futur lors de la musique en parlant
de la musique c'est vraiment un champ
pour un artiste africain un champ pour
pouvoir réfléchir pour pouvoir faire des
propositions par rapport à son
environnement immédiat par rapport à la
société
c'est vraiment un champ un champ des
possibles en fait qui est infinie c'est
un peu le procédé de mon travail
actuellement c'est vraiment de faire des
propositions pour le futur
mais dans ses propositions là je vais
puiser dans le passé
dans mon passé à moi je vais puiser dans
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui parce que
j'utilise les outils d'aujourd'hui
l'informatique la technologie
je vais puiser dans mon passé dans mais
les mythologies dans les religions noirs
et fait tout ce bagage là que je remets
nab avec moi pour faire des propositions
pour le futur en fait celui que vous
entendez en ce moment on n'est pas
souvent catalogué comme un artiste afro
futuriste mais vous l'aurez compris ce
n'est pas l'étiquette ou le look qui
compte mais bien plutôt la démarche
blick bassy olama c'est son nom en 2019
sortait un disque de toute beauté
consacré à ruben um nyobé héros de
l'indépendance du cameroun assassiné par
les forces coloniales française en 1958
et longtemps enterré dans une chape de
silence par les dirigeants des deux pays
la france et le cameroun dans l'un de
ses clips blick bassy se met dans la
peau des résistants camerounais traquer
en cette année 1958 par les colons dans
la vidéo ils sont habillés comme des
chevaliers du moyen âge et poursuivre à
cheval le maquisard camerounais lui il
court pour leur échapper et porte des
rangers c'est une kalachnikov mais aussi
des peaux de bêtes et connaît les
tubercules qui dans la forêt rendre
invisible les époques se superposent et
se télescopent un peu comme dans l'afro
futurisme tels que le formulait les
shabazz palaces aux et d'après blick
bassy rien d'étonnant à ça cette
démarche afro futuriste vaut tout autant
pour l'afrique que pour les cousins
d'amérique
oui bien sûr je pense que le saint coran
qui est parti d'une crise existentielle
les américains des nord-américains qui
je pense avec le besoin de sortir un peu
du cliché de l'afrique en général qui a
ramené tout simplement au folklore or
toutes les cultures et les communautés
on folklore également et malheureusement
ces communautés un sou vent généralement
été mêlé réduit classe autre club et le
fait d'essayer de s'approprier le futur
à travers du matériel à travers des
vêtements à travers des postures
est une recherche de l'identité de dire
que avant d'être innocent peut-être
folklorique mais nous sommes également
comme toutes les autres communautés
c'est-à-dire plurielle c'est à dire
contemporain est il donc de manière
naturelle cela résonne aussi à la
nouvelle génération africaine qui est en
pleine construction et qui vit
exactement la même crise identitaire
puisque majoritairement ces pays a été
colonisé et la même pression même pour
les africains aujourd'hui la majeure
partie pensent que l'afrique est né à
avec la colonisation quoi et donc cette
quête identitaire fait qu' il ya une
vraie recherche qui résonne à travers
des outils modernes vers le futur vers
la réappropriation est tout simplement
la réécriture de storytelling basque
important des outils du futur des choses
beaucoup plus moderne
si aussi un moyen tout simplement
d'essayer de se réclamer d'appartenir à
quelque chose de 2,2 de grandes complet
de contemporains de modane bien que
traditionnels d'ailleurs on peut dire ni
té là où c'est ultra boys and i télé
souvent pétri justement de cette
tradition aussi absolument pas ce que
c'est le fait que la tradition au centre
de sa qui vient complètement l'a décalé
et la différencier les tout le reste
parce qu'autrement elle serait tout
simplement elle ressemblerait en fait un
taux de les autres
identité visuelle et où donc c'est le
traditionnel qui vient tout simplement
décalé démontrer comment ça c'était des
outils modernes mais qui appartiennent à
une communauté un espace est une
tradition qui vient d'ailleurs et c'est
là où ça devient intéressant parce que
propos penser le futur on est obligé de
repartir aux traditions en a obligé
d'aller rechercher des outils
traditionnels pour revenir les colorées
avec des couleurs et une peinture
moderne
cette quête identitaire elle est
cruciale en fait toi parce que de plus
en plus toi je veux qu'on se rend compte
que quand on perd on perd énormément de
choses est vraiment de valeur énormément
de richesse tu vois quand on regarde la
façon dont on gère nos
nos corps notre santé et comment se
soignent cetera et cetera
toutes ces choses sont autour de nous
depuis des siècles mais pourquoi on se
rend pas compte
tu vois pourquoi on a l'impression que
c'est pas bon en fait tu vois et c'est
récurrent c'est récurrent c'est
récurrent dans notre quotidien en
afrique ce procès je dis que c'est que
les gens croient que watts ce qui est
bien fait mais ce qui quand c'est bien
fait c'est fait ailleurs l'afrique
serait elle en train de perdre les
savoir que des générations d'ancêtres
ont patiemment élaboré conserver
transmis comme le rappelait mon vieux
père soro solo la modernité occidentale
a chassé le karité cette noix dont on
fait du beurre et qui servait pour la
cuisine pour faire des onguents et bien
d'autres choses encore
donc dans les années 60 quand lui était
petit eh bien il fallait pour être
moderne laisser le karité pour les
huiles alimentaires industriels et
acheter un pour la peau des crèmes
importés cinquante ans plus tard
eh bien ce sont les grandes maisons
cosmétiques occidental qui se vantait
d'avoir du karité dans toutes leurs
pommade et leur crème
donc c'est bien de toutes ces aliénation
souvent hérités de la colonisation que
les chercheurs de futurs alternatifs
africains tentent de se débarrasser
et parmi ces aliénation dia la fable qui
fait de la technologie la solution à
tous nos maux et celle là résolument des
shabazz palaces elle n'y croit pas
dans ce titre vous parlez beaucoup
justement de cette nouvelle ère cette
nouvelle époque à laquelle nous amener
la technologie et on dirait vraiment que
c'est une époque apocalyptique et lui
fait on a cette impression parfois tard
ce temps on fois la soif des gens qui
passent leur tante le nez dans leurs
appareils et written in life est tous
dans la vie se résume à ceci change avec
les machines
saint gobain qu'on en oublie de prêter
attention à la nature aux autres humains
les communications en vie dans la
communication avec les machines demain
les gens vivent dans un monde virtuel
avec un casque les prêteurs voyageant
dans des endroits il
sont pas physiquement mais virtuellement
attaqué seul je pense que c'est une
perte pour les humains sélection
connectés de la nature à terre et c'est
vrai c'est une période mais la réalité
et se confie c'est que c'est ça le futur
les décisions c'est jusqu'ici nous
emmène droit dans cette de l'action
l'asservissement par les technologies
inquiète les auteurs africains de
science fiction
tout comme la nature et son saccage qui
sont au centre de beaucoup de récits qui
fleurissent ces dernières années c'est
vrai en littérature mais aussi au cinéma
où la jeune kényane wanuri kahiu avait
tourné un film dont l'action se passe
quelque part en territoire est africain
trente cinq ans après la troisième
guerre mondiale les humains vivent dans
une base souterraine louis car le monde
extérieur est irradié stérile vide
d'arbres et doux
à l'intérieur de cette base les hommes
produisent eux mêmes leur énergie en
pédalant sur des machines de sport un
peu comme des petits rongeurs qui tourne
dans le rond et puis l'eau qu'ils
boivent n'est que la transformation de
leur sueur et de leur urine qu'il doive
patiemment recueillir comme si c'était
de l'or voilà pour la situation jusqu'à
ce qu'une jeune femme reçoit 20
échantillons de terre de terres fertiles
elle rêve de retrouver l'endroit où elle
a été prélevé et où la vie peut-être
pourrait reprendre la science-fiction
utopique ou dystopique se développent
ces dernières années en particulier chez
les auteurs d'afrique anglophone l'afro
futurisme né aux états unis s'est
acclimaté et a bel et bien un écho sur
le continent africain en évoluant bien
sûr avec son temps alors certes certains
les puristes notamment je les entends
déjà en ont marre qu'on emploie ce mot
qui est devenu tendance récupéré par le
marketing et les marchands et oui et si
olives ou s'en est emparé avec black
panther c'est pas pour rien n'empêche il
a bel et bien ce mot il vit en afrique
et il est pertinent pour parler d'un
certain nombre d'artistes africains
c'est en tout cas ce que rappelle
oulimata guèye lé commissaire
d'exposition dans le domaine des arts
visuels et c'est avec elle que sina tout
ça qu'à avait discuté je respecte
complètement la position de coteaux et
chun qui disait mais le terme d'un
futurisme est un concept suffisamment
élastique pour qu'ils puissent être le
concept qui permet de comprendre un
certain nombre de productions
artistiques sur le continent africain
qui se posent la question effectivement
du présent ou des futurs de l'afrique
donc même si la france future is my
était quelque chose qui s'est penché
vers des productions des états unis de
la caraïbe du monde anglo saxon
principalement et qu'il ya eu peu de
référence africaine
c'est un terme qui peut être utilisée
pour comprendre
même assigné à une position de
domination forte on peut développer ses
propres outils d'émancipation et donc
cette puissance un peu politique
émancipatrice
je pense qu'il lui a donné qui lui a
donné un certain poids en fait quelque
chose dans lequel on peut aller
continuer de puiser se dire ce terme
d'âpres au futurisme
il a cette puissance que on a toujours
en position de lutter politiquement on a
cette capacité cette puissance est
intelligent cette force cette capacité
artistique de penser les moyens d outil
d'émancipation
oui en fait moi je suis pour moi tout
cela vient je passe de manière naturelle
parce que comme je suis dans ma quête
existentielle je suis dans une démarche
d'émancipation du stand après établi et
tout simplement de redéfinir les notions
de beauté les notions de leader de
bonheur de juin 2,2 et donc dans cette
réécriture par moi-même ligier
énormément de choses qui ressorte et à
partir de ce moment j'aurais créé un peu
un j'essaie de recréer juste vraiment
avec ma perspective preuve avec mme ma
vision tout ce qui m'entoure et cela pas
vraiment de la démarche interne et
intérieure qui est la mienne aujourd'hui
des vraiment m'émanciper un peu du stand
après établit donc des cases dans
lesquelles on voudrait enfermer la
culture africaine l'homme africain l'art
africain et donc j'essaye tout
simplement de la réécrire à ma façon et
pour la réécrire on est obligé d'être
futuriste parce qu'à partir du moment où
on part des choses actuelles départ des
choses contemporaines en s'émancipant de
tout ce qui est rétabli comme standard
comme case on est obligé quelque part de
repenser des choses il ya partie moment
on est dans une démarche de repenser et
de réécriture
oui on est obligé d'être futuriste
futuriste en tout cas ce qui est certain
c'est que dans ce mot afro futurisme
dans les possibles sens qu'il peut avoir
eh bien on retrouve toutes les questions
parfois souterraine qui vont et viennent
de part et d'autre de l'atlantique noir
qui sommes nous tous vous ne vous ou à
lons nous
comment décider pour nous mêmes autant
de questions universelles mais qui pour
les peuples qui ont vécu l'esclavagé la
colonisation prennent un sens
particulier oui parce qu'il s'agit de
convertir ce poids de l'histoire en
force
et si possible concrètement le
panafricanisme du 20e siècle on était
une magnifique tentatives et en ce sens
je me suis toujours dit que kwame
n'krumah le premier président du ghana
était lui aussi trop futuriste
le prof souleymane bachir diagne sur ce
point était d'accord avec moi mais je
suis et je suis d'accord pour le dire je
crois qu'elle cancre au moins elle
n'arrête pas de dire ma fille cammas
chine l'afrique doit s'unir
c'est de la fausse futurisme quand il
dit et en particulier il prend des
accents messianiques
on se souvient que les labels raison de
la pluie le rédempteur et il prend des
accents messianiques en citant
d'ailleurs les évangiles en disant
prenez le royaume politique de l'unité
et le reste vous sera donnée de sur quoi
et ça c'est la démarche même de la flore
futurisme séances de projection
volontariste dans un futur brillant qui
est au fond la promesse promet ce
plaindre
la terre promise et cette démarche
politique qui était à la fois une
démarche pratique fils il a travaillé à
mettre en place que les mécanismes qui
ont conduit à l'indépendance du ghana et
la mise en place d'un état de nerfs mais
également avec ses accents messianiques
de terre promise
c'est la démarche même de la flf
utilisons
oui krouma embrassait dans sa vision
d'une afrique libre tous les peuples
d'afrique et tous les enfants de la
diaspora
aussi fallait-il qu'il soit uni c'est à
lui que l'on doit justement cette idée
des états unis d'afrique qui sont depuis
20 ans une réalité et qu'on fait à
abidjan aujourd'hui dans ma prochaine
transmission je vous parlerai justement
de visionnaire qui inventent très
concrètement des futurs africain et
qu'il est réaliste ou là il faut que je
vous laisse
il ya une alerte tempête magnétique et
ça c'est la seule chose qui nous menace
vraiment ici il faut que j'aie bontoux
jeu coûte